so what do you miss about doing a talk
show well I miss the human interest
segments and what I love about your show
is how you focus on the human interest
segment so much because there's only so
much of celebrities you can see without
you know like year five you're going to
be going oh my God it's that guy from
the soap opera again you know it's kind
of hard to interview someone nine or ten
times yeah but the human interest
stories always made me cry and broke my
heart and I was so happy to give people
the spotlight for a moment people who
deserve it who never really get it and I
love how you guys do that on this show
it's my favorite part your show is live
though live every day I mean I two words
they could never make my show live
because I curse like a sailor that's
three words
but like I I don't know if I could do it
live that must have been really hard
well I had so many years as a stand-up
comic so that was really helpful but I
really wanted to do it because I didn't
want some studio executive to come in
and say you know I didn't really like
the Dom DeLuise cooking saying would you
do that again you know I didn't want to
have to redo something and try to make
what's spontaneous and real taped you
know I wanted to keep it as live as a
live performance of stand-up so that was
sort of my choice and we did it in New
York so that we could go live to all the
earliest clearances yeah and I loved it
that way I felt like that hour that I
was on TV was the funnest hour of my day
I think people I not people so much are
worried I worry for me and what comes
out of my mouth
have you ever done anything I like to be
able to edit me I was gonna say have you
ever done anything where you told them
take that out what I just said well I
went through a pretty rough two years
where sometimes look we're human yes and
I would say something like maybe that
wasn't maybe I shouldn't say that yeah
so yeah no yeah I definitely have edited
myself I think my mother appreciates it
as well yeah yeah my family sometimes
yeah my family sometimes says to me did
you have to tell them that you know I'm
like well everything is you know
material but it's relatable relatable
and I think it's relatable everybody
goes through stuff like that but it is
fun though I like we're you just stand
up I'm a musician yes the live energy
though you can't you can't beat that you
can't beat it at all that's why I love
the audience at least we have the
audience like you you get that
interaction
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
s